In this section of our course, we will take a look at the face and body control rig assets
and how we can use these for a forward and backward solve.
We will also look at how to apply animations with and without sequencer and then go over
the body IK retargetor assets and facial animation tools.
We can instantly start to animate metahumans with the body and face control rig which become
accessible once we add a metahuman into sequencer.
Let's jump into Unreal Engine and take a look at the control rig assets.
Inside of Unreal Engine, we can locate the body and face control rig assets a few different
ways.
One way is to select the metahuman in the level.
Then in the details panel, we will start by selecting the body component and then opening
up the skeletal mesh.
Inside of the skeletal mesh asset, in the asset details panel, we can scroll all the
way down to the default animating rig.
This is where the body control rig asset is assigned.
When we double click on this, it may take a moment to open.
In the viewport, the female medium normal body weight preview mesh will be assigned
as this is the shared skeleton.
In the rig graph, over here, we have the forward solve control rig setup.
This is what allows us to create animations by selecting controls that can be adjusted
using forward or inverse kinematics.
Over here, we have the backwards solve setup, which allows us to bake animations to the
control rig and adjust existing animations.
Now, let's go back to the main viewport and locate the face control rig the same way.
With the metahuman still selected in the viewport, we can go to the details panel and
select the face component.
Let's open up the face skeletal mesh and then locate the default animating rig in the asset
details panel.
And now let's open this.
In the viewport, the face archetype skeleton is assigned as this is shared by all metahumans.
This also has a forward and backward solve setup.
This is where the forward solve is located.
You can take some time if you wish to inspect this and see how this is constructed.
Over here, this is where the backward solve is located.
This has been organized so that we can locate where certain controls have been mapped out.
If we move over and zoom in on the jaw controls, we can see the minimum and maximum values
they have assigned to them.
Now before we continue, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
The body control rig asset located in the common folder is set up with a forward solve
and backward solve.
It is also set up for controls to be adjusted using forward and inverse kinematics.
We can also locate the control rig assets by either going to the common folder or by
opening up the skeletal mesh and then inside of the asset details panel, it will be assigned
as the default animating rig.
The face control rig asset can be found in the common face folder and is also set up
to use a forward and backward solve.
A forward solve allows you to create animations by moving the controls and setting keys for
those controls.
A backward solve allows you to adjust an existing animation by baking the animation to the control
rig.
You can then edit the existing animation curves or you can add on top of the existing
animation with an additive layer.
Let's return back to Unreal Engine and take a look at how we can use the control rigs.
We saw in the metahuman introduction class that we can use a forward solve to create
an animation.
You can choose if you want to use FK or IK for certain controls.
To do this, first locate the global control track.
If I use this drop down arrow and then scroll down to here, this is where we can switch
between FK and IK.
We can switch the arms from FK to IK by checking these on.
By default, the legs are set to IK.
There is also a switch for the spine where we can move all three spine controls together
and there is a switch for the head and neck.
To create an animation using the control rig, select a control.
I'm going to change the gizmo to translate and then set a neutral key by pressing the
letter S or by setting a key inside of the animation details panel or inside of sequencer
over here.
Then move a few frames over and move the control.
I will set this to rotate and we'll make a few adjustments to the arm IK control.
And then I will press S to set a key.
You can continue adjusting controls until you are happy with the animation.
If you want to export this animation as an animation sequence, you can go to the body
component by scrolling all the way up here and then right click on the body component
and select bake to animation sequence.
Once you select this, you can name your animation.
I will name this forward solve and then select a folder you want to direct it to.
I will save it in the course topics folder and when you press OK, leave everything at
default and then select export to animation sequence.
Now we can go to the course topics folder.
I will double click on this to open it and I will dock this window up here.
Now it will be easier to see our animation by changing the skeletal mesh in this window.
Go up here to the top right and in the preview mesh, use the drop down and select this skeletal
mesh.
With this skeletal mesh assigned, if we scrub through here, we can see the animation we
just created using a forward solve.
Now before we move on, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
When a metahuman is added to sequencer, the body and face control rigs will appear by
default.
We can use the body control rig with a forward solve by moving controls and setting keys
for them.
You can set keys by pressing the letter S or in the animation details panel or in sequencer.
The body control rig comes with both forward and inverse kinematics.
FK allows you to rotate individual controls by adjusting the pitch, roll and yaw.
IK allows you to move a hierarchy of joints and you can adjust the pitch, roll, yaw and
also move it in the X, Y and Z location.
You can switch between FK and IK in the global control track and there are switches for the
arms, legs, spine, neck and head.
Just keep in mind, each FK-IK switch is keyable.
If you are switching between FK and IK, the FK-IK keys will be disabled in that track
if a switch key is not set.
Now let's continue by taking a look at the face control rig.